- Let's get to something sure to bring
a little more joy to
your day, well hopefully.
This is What I'm Liking.
(jazzy musical intro)
That starts with a
videographer named Tonda.
She walked into a room to
find her three-year-old son
jumping on their coffee table.
He was mimicking a cartoon on the TV.
Not surprisingly, the table broke.
That turned out to be a
pivotal moment for Tonda.
Instead of buying a new table,
she set out to make a new one herself.
I should point out that
she'd never actually
built anything before,
but that first table led
to a full fledged business
and a way to give back to the community.
From She Slangs Wood,
let's say hi to Tonda
who watches it 3:00 PM on our partner
station TMJ4, what's up?
(cheering)
- What's up, Kelly? How you doin?
- I am so good, but oh my gosh,
I have to lead with, you are
such a beautiful lot of a woman
and I like your shop.
That looks fun and I
want to build something.
So how did this grow from one
table into a whole business?
- You know, I am so proud that
just from watching YouTube videos,
I was able to build a table, right?
(laughter)
I made a Facebook post and
unexpectedly, about 30 requests later,
there were 30 people asking me
to build the same table for them.
You know, it was quite wild, quite wild.
And we were in the middle of the pandemic,
I wasn't making the same amount
of money as I normally make
with my business.
I decided, hey, I can make,
I can sell 300, $400 each with the table
and pay my bills.
And, you know, it was a
survival tactic, you know?
- Oh my gosh, by the way,
I loved all those tables that I just saw.
That's why they're asking.
I love the wide plank on the top,
that was, I might want one.
So you're teaching your
community these skills as well,
right?
- Absolutely.
So, She Slangs Wood,
since the pandemic has kind
of eased up a little bit,
I have turned it into more
of a mentorship program.
I want to teach women like,
hey, you can do this yourself.
You don't have to wait for
anybody to do this type of work,
you can do it yourself.
With the money that we
raised with She Slangs Wood,
I was able to purchase a building
within the Harambee
neighborhood, here in Milwaukee,
which is near and dear to our community.
I'm able to do that type of
work with the community members
in our neighborhood.
The overall goal is to eliminate poverty
within that neighborhood.
And we want to create some dollars
and we want people to be just
uplifted in that neighborhood,
pretty much.
- That's a beautiful thing
and a beautiful idea.
I want you to have a TV
show and I would watch it.
(laughter)
Thank you so much Tonda.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- Thank you.
- All right, well, that's not all
our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they'll be using their
friction erasable pen
to write you a check for $1,000,
how's that sound?
(cheering)
- Yes!